Eddie Wu is much more than a maths
teacher with over 1.5 million YouTube
subscribers a tedx talk and numerous
published books but his love for
teaching has grown a program aimed at
helping schools across his home state I
lead the mathematics growth team which
is a program that embeds expert teachers
into schools so that they remain current
in their practice and can support their
fellow teachers by delivering
professional learning Maria is one of 15
expert teachers training at her assigned
High School through her own class as
well as supporting teachers in
surrounding schools over my teaching
career I have had lots of people say to
me that maths was their worst subject at
school so this is a program that's
designed to help teachers make maths
more engaging the program is also hoping
to attract more trained Math teachers
into New South Wales schools with a
shortage in the department through
school workshops ran by Eddie himself I
visit schools around the state up as far
as Lismore and down to Aubry because we
want to really enthuse students about
how powerful mathematics can be and how
it enriches their lives and also show
teachers what's possible and give them
energy because teaching is a hard gig so
far a positive response has emerged from
the assigned schools from both students
and teachers the fact that it is here to
help us understand math a little more in
depth it's going to help a lot it's
really cool to like see it in person and
see how he works
kilihari win news